hello everybody my name is markiplier
and welcome to Flora's fruit farm now
before you say anything I honestly do
not know why I own this game and I'm not
just saying that like oh I saw it and it
seems silly I bet it's gonna be a fun
episode no on Christmas Day of 2009 and
I'm not just pulling that out of my ass
here's video proof I bought it on
Christmas Day of 2009 and I don't know
why why did I buy this game number one
why did I buy this game and number two
why on Christmas Day and number three
why have I never played it
I don't usually buy games that I don't
play what drove me to this madness to
buy it and it's made by IDUs Interactive
the company that made Deus Ex and
whatever they else the hell they did I
don't even know what am I talking about
so we're gonna play Flores fruit farm
and it's gonna be fun wow what a
beautiful day to explore my new home Wow
wait maybe this fruit belongs to
somebody put it's your new home huh huh
huh let me help you sir hey you miss for
your kindness you shall have these magic
loves they have the power to grow
delicious fruit with these Oh oh my god
I have no idea why I own this the magic
gloves I gave you are the secret to my
impressive garden they let you grow
fantastic fruit trees with these I'll
show you how don't mind me showing up on
your property out of the blue and yes my
garden so don't worry about anything
okay let's start by growing an apple
tree click the you grow girl trick
what's the you grow girl trick Oh what
are you doing there
what are you doing what are you getting
ready for I don't wanna know
singing neared remix to grow faster
hover your mouse over the part of the
tree you want to grow and your clothes
will work their magic Oh Oh God that
face
oh the old man's face yeah perfect
the number in the top left shows you how
many fruits the tree will bear and how
many you've discovered hey oh god what
I'm again sylvans oh god what a plate
that the three grow notes represent your
growing power and my growing power too
you can only grow a tree if you grow
notes available grow your tree to find
some fruit hmm oh god what the hell
that's so cool hey hey you found an
apple see how you only have to grow
notes now when Friz found it uses up one
grow note yeah okay anyway I'll teach
you how to cut the first Apple down
first you'll need to stop growing the
tree click to stop growing button
control your power young lady you need
to be wise about what you do with those
growth powers who knows what it could
grow yeah oh god I didn't mean it to
turn out like this let's cut down that
Apple click the cut it out trick Oh God
oh man some sorry jeez I just got
violently ill for a second it was like
Wayde disappeared in my mind
now click the fruit you want to cut down
that voice not easy to do click the
Apple hey how'd you do that
what kind of black magic [ __ ] do we
have going on here what did you do can
you go up to random strangers and just
snip your fingers together and they lose
their fruit
why don't we grow more of your tree to
find your apples
select the you grow girl trick okay here
we go
how I don't know what you're doing
I mean operating under the assumption
that you actually are singing and not
doing some horrible death black magic
here oh oh
looky-loo that you found both the apples
when you use all your grow knows you
will automatically stop growing the tree
uh I mean it's hard it doesn't seem like
it's horrible but something's obviously
going wrong here where did this old man
get these magic gloves why is this this
randomly accepted obviously there's a
price to pay for these amazing magic
tricks that you're able to do and this
old man isn't trustworthy I've played a
lot of horror games this is how they
usually start just his face oh nice
apples lady when you asking that some
space you'll be able to collect them
click on the stall down to your basket
okay why I'm pretty sure yeah great now
she's like the other Apple you're a real
natural I think I can trust you with
another secret see how big the fruit in
my gardener the region is super-sized us
this is made from special red fairy dust
I'll give you some one red fairy dust is
used every time use super-sized trick
why don't you use it on me okay I am so
sorry everybody I am so sorry I led you
into watching this horrible video of
mine alright just spend the entire
episode making fun of a stupid game
what's not that stupid actually it's
actually pretty cool fee these gloves
are awesome can I grow trees anywhere
you sure could let me show you around
I've lost the energy to grow enough
fruit to keep the locals happy let alone
attract the tourists we use a have hi oh
sorry this lady
hey why are you going now everyone else
is gone it's no fun around here
I'm Huckleberry Finn by the way I'm just
gonna go down on an adventure wait I bet
I can restore life to Clementine Valley
with my magic gloves can you imagine
this lady just going around town my
magic gloves can make plants grow I sing
to them and I sprinkle very does to make
them better and then I cut them down
with my mind I'm gonna revitalize
revitalize if you do maybe everyone will
return again oh boy oh it's a whole
world oh my goodness this is amazing Wow
we can see the whole club attack Valley
how much more of this am I gonna play I
have no idea is that your cottage flora
the one that I was sneakily creepin
around and then remember how I gave you
those gloves you owe me a lot by the way
I hope you can do this how are how many
customers you'll be able to serve by
floating time
what kind of custom huh what's good it's
your house I mean it old man's gonna be
wandering out outside it but why is
there gonna be a whole bunch of people
to buy apples outside your own house
all right whatever you know what I don't
even care I don't even care whatever I
get it I get it
I'm just gonna it's gonna give this tree
a [ __ ] until it grows fruit like
that's pretty much what I'm doing right
now
I mean not to make it weirder oh hey
random strange lady cool glad you're
here but I got business that ladies
should have a lot more questions and I
don't know why she has a bunch of hearts
because I'm pretty sure these apples are
the ones that poison snow light light
wait
my jokes are awesome here you go Apple
Apple for your face magically fairy dust
induce magic club filled apples
I sang to it this morning I'm sure
you'll like it
hey did you just bleed coins out of your
wrists wahoo they're making my it looks
like more cursors are all the way so
keep them waiting to log where they'll
get angry and leave for some damn reason
I don't know there's something by your
house but they're really pissed off hey
faster you serve your customers the
happier the old lb and the bigger the
tip ever you know what I mean can i oh I
guess I'm on my own no old man come back
I am I'm very sad without you because
for some reason I I actually enjoyed
your company quite a lot don't mind me
and my weird black magic it's all good
it's all good there you go oh you own
two there there you go I don't want to
play I'm done I'm very much done I'll
get through to the end of this day I
suppose it's almost over anyway hi
farmer Joe I just got damn and I'm not
yeah all right
I'm out of fruit just shut up old lady
wait your your twin came by
I guess alright whatever you know it's
fine old lady you don't get any
I appreciate the twins you already got
one this morning don't go back
again I know I'm no I'm good I'm good
no no I'm good I'm good I'm good
I'm pretty good I'm good now I'm good
I'm okay
my hmm my curiosity has been satiated I
still don't know why I bought this game
why did I buy this game why did I buy it
on Christmas why did I buy it and never
play it what was wrong with me what
happened that Christmas I don't even
remember what that Christmas was about
why why was I buying random Steam games
okay anyway so I'm sorry you had to
suffer through the horror that was
Flora's fruit farm I hope you enjoyed
this video if you want to see a 13-part
series of Flora's fruit farm let me know
in the comments below and if you don't
I'll make it a 20 part series it's
win-win situation either way thank you
again everybody so much for watching and
as always I will see you in the next
video matter the audience wrong for hire
something you're an idiot like why would
anyone
[ __ ] what the [ __ ] don't do that oh he's
so cute he's too cute I would you'd go
to hell and die so cute